signori devo cambiare videocamera perché
voglio me prendere un obiettivo che ci
faccia raggiungere il nostro obiettivo
this iscrivetevi oggi c'è il gioco che
fa per me che molti di voi già
conosceranno perché si tratta di un
replay è di uno dei giochi che ha fatto
sempre la storia del mio canale e si
tratta di organisti qui in tutta la sua
magnificenza di questo menù che trasuda
emozioni
si tratta di questo ladro che noi
impersoniamo che deve rubare delle cose
in casa prima che il proprietario arrivi
e lo scopra se ci scopre sono cavoli
amari vabbè andiamo in un gioco questa
roba da 80 anni quindi non mi ricordo
assolutamente vediamo di non fare figure
barbine art by elise leblanc ma posso
già partire bene io sono in casa sono
già in casa di questa persona che ancora
deve arrivare c'è un koala a posso
rubare il koala va bene non so quanto
possa valere un koala però lasciamo li
ricordavo il quale nuovo all'anno
aggiornarci sono di quale in casa ma che
poi è il problema che è successo
robe da prendere in prestito certo il
ritratto di una di una lady il ritratto
di una lady va bene quello non lo
sappiamo
eccola la juve questo il ritratto della
lady il primo giusto thank you micro
wave microonde o se riesco a prendere
tutto alla painting innanzi tutto eccolo
qua già su due fondi quale in casa la
cosa servono
be go along monet malware non ho idea di
che cosa sia l'uomo air lo scoprì ecco
chi sono ladri non poco acculturati
ragazzi purtroppo quasi un anello quello
è il premier è l'unica cosa di valore
che non ho preso però non lo fa prendere
ed i phone skeeter barbecue e gold bar
una barretta d'oro a bagnoli sopra
ragazzi non so dove si possa trovare
questa roba qua vediamo
buongiorno ecco la chitarra via la
chitarra un'idea di che cosa sia un
lamone ragazzi qualcuno sa l'inglese
igoogle traduci la un malware tagliaerba
che ha fatto che kaká bene mi sono
attaccato un po sotto qui lo mauer
bollire tagliaerba chiarissimo grazie
google non ho idea di dove spinge ma non
c'è il giardino e sta a casa ragazzi
stranissima sta roba più soldi questi ti
posso rubare questi li posso rubare che
strano posso rubare di soldi va bene
eccolo qua no perché mi stupisce visto
che non prenderò che di valore
ti servono cuffie e un tagliaerba robe
del genere per caso lo avete no
headphone barbecue dove devo prendere le
robe che non troverò mai qua o alla
cassaforte ecco questa qua non so il
codice quindi ancora no però vabbè
tagliaerba dove troviamo tagliaerba
decente penso ci sarà il garage no
immagino il garage da perché non mi
ricordo se c'è chi eccolo qua una chiave
posso arrivare lì sopra perfetto il
telefono lasciamolo quanto non è di
valore gli perfora eccolo qua loro mauer
grandissimo un low power ho proprio
bisogno parte cue prendilo poi dove me
ne sto mettendo ste cose escluso non è
possibile nel deretano direttamente va
bene
no non sarebbe una macchina awlaki è
arrivato il tizio porca vacca mi
mancavano due cose da fare veloce andare
a pianista propria che mi scopro vaia
velocissimo la chiave cose che apre la
chiave questo perfetto ecco le cuffie e
la barretta loro dove 9432 9432 dovrà
assolutamente aprire la cassaforte prima
che il tipo mi scopro speriamo non venga
di sopra aperto la aperto aperta per tu
chiudi 9432
[Musica]
no mi ha trovato è un canguro come ho
perso tutto preso tutto porca vacca
il proprietario è un canguro fermi aiuto
aiuto ci hanno fatto però è scattato
l'allarme non so come va ce lo fa ha
preso tutto us che ho preso tutto soldi
guarda che roba fortissimo non hanno mai
finita al primo tentativo che è bello il
primo tentativo è finito in un lieto
fine questo urge una un festeggiamento
ok basta c'è un altro tentativo ma c'è
un altro tentativo cambiano le cose ogni
volta per rendere il gioco ovviamente un
po più vario e veniva cosa mi hanno dato
di rubare stavolta sempre a microonde
possa fare i micro onde sto tizio
perfetto tostapane di del dildo di
gerbido digerito c'è un digerito
boomerang ed i fondi ci del camera gol
fa eco al can do sexo costa i pani
eccolo qua via le bottiglie arquette
guarda ecco il boomerang
ecco gli iphones non sia un digerito
ragazzi però per digerire tipo a
citrosodina non lo so non capiscono
avanti chiavi dove la chiave dove la
chiave prima che non mi dico più fi
veloce bianca livi lo zio che manca
pochissimo che però non ho capito perché
un canguro ma vabbè di citare ecco la
digital camera mezzanotte arrivato a
questo di gelido
no ragazzi non capisco che non so che
cosa sia è un risotto prendiamo delle
robe per per arrivare alla porta per
aprirla non so parlare rubiamo anche un
dizionario ho digerito eccolo era il
copriletto non era il caso che metti sul
letto che non ha mai avuto un nome si
chiama digerito ragazzi la chiave stacco
ad anello che lo prenderei volentieri ma
non posso perché sono un ladro ma con
della dignità
manca solo piano di sopra pazzesco
ragazzo fortissimo ho fatto più veloce
di prima c'è il tipo non arriva in tempo
vinto senza che arriva se il tizio
fantastico era un ladro organizzato
eccola qua la porta goldmark non c'è
procede cosa qua se sta roba
1317 molto chiazze tac no come error
come erano 13 17 17 317 porco schifo
73 17 porca che ho sbagliato scusate
aiuto non so se faccio in tempo
porca vacca non si sia aperta dove
arriva a tizio volevi eccolo giorno fa
che cosa ho visto si sta ingrossando una
sedia 37mila ammazzo lanteri costò
canguro bello e sono fortissimo non
pensavo di essere così forte vorrei
essere più scarso ma me la cavo il mio
gioco che vi devo dire
si può fare un altro tipo di mappa
facciamo mai speedrun vediamo se
riusciamo a 10 da camera e già perso
non puoi finire su giochi 22 secondi sei
pazzo vaso prendere tutto dj diamond
ring
eccola degli avanti adesso lo posso
prenderla e veloce lascerà certo questo
non faccio più lento nelle altre volte
stavolta in corso dinanzi a sogni grazia
ho già perso l'altro l'ha già vinto
porco demonio come è possibile
com'è possibile che ci ha messo così
poco chiave che anello perfetto
lasciamo stare i soldi chi se ne frega
lo batte il record a bicicletta porco
schifo dove eccola ok tablet digital
camera digerito gold barcia posso fare
vagli sopra il solito lì dove perfetto
record italiano raga recor italiano qua
dove la camera maledizione l'ho persa
era qua era qua prima porca vacca allora
messo alla camera
ho perso già la chiave era dove porco le
mani eccolo qua il tablet e non questo
il telefono schifoso telefono servì a
niente
apri camera dica ecco tablet camera a 4
6 4 3 4 6 4 6 4 6 4 3 4 c 4 thread che
andai via tutto piaciuto via tutto
effetto manca non digerito che cosa del
divano e la digital camera e per me ne
vado a quel paese dove il digerito deve
essere su un divano digerito dov'è orco
demonio o quasi dice poi di digerito mi
sono perso
è una speed run dei miei stivali questa
mannaia dov'è il digerito dai che schifo
perché ci soggetto inutile nella mia
vita cosa serve ragazzi ho fatto più
schifo di prima ho fatto molto più
schifo di prima perché non ho trovato il
digerito purtroppo e allora niente non
riesco a trovare digitato niente da dare
a da speed run è diventata nera normale
in cui devo sopravvivere perché non sa
che sono poi ancora la il tizio posso
chiudermi dentro
eccola porco demonio porco dove sto
digerito il maledetto ogni volta a a ma
porca a capo anche a chiudi ti aiuto mi
ha seguita dall armadio chiuso dentro
però lo chiudo nelle cose ragano stato
verso digerito dove tre in quale posso
prendere un quale invece di quello che
serve top maya schifosa e non so dove
sto coso ragazze aiuto non ho trovato il
digerito ragab è fresco lo stesso non
posso uscire da trovarlo per forza ma se
chi è in faccia un canguro ragazzi non
lo trovo non lo trovo aiuto stampa del
buon vino non gli piace il vino vino non
piace che auguri nota con parco demonio
volevo farla spingerà ne sono morto
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto che sarà davvero gli organi ed
tiff e compatto che non ci giocava
saranno almeno stati
tre anni se non di più e niente sono
contenta di valori giocato per voi era
uno dei replay che dovevo assolutamente
fare bene sapere se c'è un altro
giochino che volete che io riporto che
vedevi semplicità ragazza una società
civile piace non mi piace mai visto già
capito d'iniziare se non sapresti
iscrivetevi come sempre ci vediamo ad un
prossimo vita
beh ragazzi
[Musica]